tonight i come to talk about
crisis and opportunity
about rebuilding the nation revitalizing
our democracy
and winning the future for america
i stand here tonight one day shy
of the hundredth day of my
administration
100 days since i took the oath of office
and lifted my hand
off our family bible and inherited a
nation
we all did that was in crisis the worst
pandemic in a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
now after just 100 days
i can report to the nation america
is on the move again
100 days ago america's house was on fire
we had to act and thanks the
extraordinary leadership of speaker
pelosi
majority leader schumer and the
overwhelming support of the american
people democrats independents and
republicans
we did act together we passed the
american rescue plan
one of the most consequential rescue
packages in american history
we're already seeing the results
we're already seeing the results
after i promised we'd get 100 million
covet 19 vaccine shots
into people's arms in 100 days we will
have provided over
220 million coveted shots in those
hundred days
thanks to all the help of all of you
[Applause]
during these hundred days an additional
000 americans enrolled in the affordable
care act
when i established a special sign up
period to do that 800 000
in that period we're making one of the
largest one-time
ever investments ever in improving
health care for veterans
critical investments to address the
opioid crisis
and maybe most importantly thanks to the
american rescue plan we're on track
to cut child poverty in america in half
this year
and in the process
all this was all going on the economy
created
more than 1 million 300 000 new jobs in
100 days
more jobs with first
more jobs in the first hundred days than
any president
on record the international monetary
fund
the international monetary fund
is now estimating our economy will grow
at a rate of more than six percent this
year
that will be the fastest pace of
economic growth in this country in
nearly four decades
america's moving moving forward
but we can't stop now